[Musique]
pourquoi on est chez vous vous êtes pas
cuisinier dans l'avion dont le nom
serait génial mais je suis à l'arrêt
forcé sais que j'ai un gros d'arrêt pour
le bureau que les jeux se chercher un
mot clé mais journée que le consulter il
aux différents organismes de charité
comme j'aime cuisiner sous le timbre
aussi joindre l'utile à l'agréable
vous avez trouvé un organe et c'est que
j'ai trouvé oui hein l'organisme
rappelle coup de pouce qui est dans
l'est de la ville de montréal veut
distribuer des plots à différentes
personnes
[Musique]
savez vous combien de patience avant
prochain c'est vraiment je vais vraiment
proximité
[Musique]
je préparais le demofoonte a été un vrai
succès les gens d'avoir des mof une
maison c'est pour cela ça semblait les
réconforter pour moi c'est juste moi
c'est primordial de faire quelque chose
parce que j'ai la chance d'avoir est
d'abord un tour pouvoir manger c'est
pourquoi tout le monde le sait c'est
normal de revenir
c'est uniquement ça ça me permet de un
peu l'aspect logistique de cuisine et
des plus grandes quantités
j'aime le défi d'avoir la figure et les
quantités et puis de ne pas perdre
d'aliments de semaine j'avais les jolis
mots fut un jour faire une crème de
carottes et pommes et puis le fait comme
une variation porter chinois avec pare
brise et petits pois oignons caramélisés
avec les pommes de table et voilà aucune
dit de kiki vinivi prendre la bouffe à
ce programme longtemps que sa puce faire
un repos réconfortant à quelqu'un ou sam
sam suffit
[Musique]
c'est vous qui êtes un grand merci
la semaine dernière renault afin plus de
350 rapport donc tout azimut végétarien
vegas vient d'eux
cuisine qui fournit la nourriture
j'ai des spas bénévole j'ai un commando
c'est incroyable dans ma xiuhong d'ipo
j'ai le sentiment qu'en lan je pense que
la vc3 l'ip et le combier une personne
d'aller pour nourrir avec ce monde mais
je voudrais le sujet au moins 40 portion
pratiquement deux parties
noah puis de se pousser là en 40 et 50
portion
m
moi ce qu'elle n'est pas capable
d'amener dans le maître courte et
plombières
on sait qu'il ya des personnes par
exemple qui viennent seuls mais que y
ont de la misère à se déplacer donc on
veut leur en donner plus pour qui peu se
profiter pendant deux semaines au moins
avant de voir revenir la pandémie c'est
vraiment une crise planétaire qui
vraiment ne débouche noir mais qui fait
que notre vitalité
les gens cherchent le connaissez poussé
mon et bilou c'est quand je vois pas
après deux jours loge commence la bande
du lips au téléphone c'est vraiment
incroyable
oui merci beaucoup je dis bravo pour ce
que vous faites merci beaucoup
[Musique]